william rag has made some pretty serious
allegations this morning he suggested
that colleagues were intimidated that
they were threatened to have money
withdrawn from their constituencies
he says it's blackmail and that they
should report it to the police and he's
also talked about officials briefing
embarrassing stories to the press i've
spoken to nps who recognized some of
that are those tactics being used to try
to stop mp speaking out against you i've
i've seen no evidence her knowns to
support any of those uh allegations
anushka and what i'm focused on is what
we're doing to deal with the number one
priority of the british people which is
coming through covid
and we've made enormous progress thanks
to the to the vaccine rollout fastest in
in europe the booster campaign has
enabled us to open up uh we're moving
back to the
status quo antibacter to plan a uh
opening up our economy we've got the
most open economy in society in
in europe uh fastest growth in the g7 as
a result of that booster campaign but
we have this
huge
issue we have to deal with which is the
number of people
who sadly did not come forward for for
scans or screens uh during cobit we've
got to fix uh those backlogs that's why
why i'm here today this uh this
fantastic diagnostic center i mean i'm
telling you that i'm hearing evidence
from mps will you look for that evidence
of course but what we're what we're
focused on
is what we can do to
clear the covid backlogs and i just must
stress how vital that is anushka we
we've got we're putting money into the
nhs and that's crucial we're supporting
our amazing doctors and nurses who've
kept us going throughout the pandemic
there are 44 000
more health care professionals now in
the nhs than there were in 2020. that's
a great thing but but the waiting list
they're tired and they're stressed and
what we've got to do
is make life easier for them
by helping to by ensuring we have
diagnostics
done as fast as possible on sites like
this that's what we're doing
so you will look for evidence one of
your colleagues told me that you're in a
bullish mood and you certainly sound
more confident you clearly focus very
much on covid your aides tell us that if
there is a leadership contest you'd
fight it are they right anushka i
admire your journalism but i just got to
tell you i'm focused on what i think is
the number one issue for
the british people and it is clearing
the code of backgrounds but also
looking at what we can do with new
techniques and so diagnostics is so much
part of the delay if you need treatment
if you if you need to if you have
you're worried about cancer you need to
get a screen or a scan and what is
happening is too often people are simply
being delayed because they can't get it
in time now we're putting 3.2 2.3
billion i should say into 100 new
diagnostics hubs community
diagnostics hubs
to bring that screen that scan closer to
you but also to take the pressure off
the acute sector so that people don't
have to go into the hospital to get the
treatment and so that we can speed it up
if you look at the waiting list and we
are looking absolutely uh ruthlessly at
these waiting lists eighty percent of
the delay is caused by either waiting to
see a specialist a consultant or waiting
for diagnostics the rest is just is
waiting for a procedure like a hip or a
heart operation or whatever but so if
you can speed up diagnostics
uh making use of uh community
diagnostics hubs that we're investing in
around the country uh you can make a we
we hope will make a huge difference the
problem is that i do understand what you
want to focus on but the questions about
leadership are really important and
people want answers you've said quite
clearly that we should wait until sue
gray reports can i just get from you a
guarantee that if she points the finger
at you that you will take action that
you would resign and if she points
fingers at others that you would as
sajid javid suggested this morning
take action against them
anushka i just want to repeat what i've
said uh the the the issue for for me
today and and and but i'm asking you
about i understand that i understand
that people find it hard to understand
you say you didn't know that i
understand i understand why i've said
said that i've said a lot about all
those uh all those people are wondering
if you understood the rules and
what we're focused on what i'm focused
on uh today with the greatest respect
and i've said an awful lot about all
those uh all those issues okay what
we're focused on is community diagnosis
i understand you've said that and you're
not going to answer that question i'm
making a huge one of your remember that
we hope to make did defect yesterday i
do just want to ask if you knew that was
coming and are you worried others would
do the same
i appreciate that your desire to take
the take the conversation back to to
that issue i think the number one
priority for government for me
personally is
looking at the state of our country as
we come out
of
with covid we hope
we hope that we're now on a a route map
uh back to complete normality we've been
able to to move from uh plan b back to
the status quo ante back to to plan a
people can go back to work i think it's
important that people
uh remain
cautious
but what we need to do above all now is
look at the the landscape the health
landscape post covid and do everything
in our power
to get people the treatment they need
and i've the message i want to really to
to get over to people is if you haven't
had a screen you haven't had a scan
you've been delayed or put off because
of kobit then now is the time thank you
very much about ukraine prime minister
ukraine i'll do ukraine yes come on four
questions
leadership four answers on covered one
on ukraine please yes president biden
has said russia is likely to move in
nobody wants a full-blown war have you
spoken to the prime minister have you
spoken to the president how can this be
de-escalated yes so the
as you know there was a there was a
there was a a
uh
what they call a quint discussion so
france german italy uh uk and uh and the
united states
about this and
look be in no doubt that if
russia
were to make any kind of incursion into
ukraine
of any uh on any scale
whatever i think that that would be a uh
disaster for
[Music]
not just for ukraine but for russia it
would disaster for the world and the uk
stands squarely between behind the the
sovereignty and integrity of
ukraine